on vit à défaut d'avoir strictement
atteint la parité hommes femmes en
matière politique on se réjouira de la
stricte parité euro dollar
au chapitre économique ainsi aujourd'hui
un euro valait exactement un dollar la
monnaie européenne s'apprécie ce qui
fait les affaires de ceux qui voyagent
aux états unis notamment en revanche
pour les entreprises qui exportent ce
n'est pas une bonne nouvelle explication
amaury guibert et alain poiré dans cette
agence de voyages il se passe quelque
chose d'étonnant avec les etats unis une
destination délaissé depuis le 11
septembre
et pourtant on peut constater que la
demande est beaucoup plus importante que
l'offre
et aujourd'hui il est difficile d'avoir
un à billets pour les états unis
ici les places manquent c'est qu'il est
devenu moins cher de voyager outre
atlantique grâce à l'euro il n'avait
cessé de baisser depuis sa création
puis il s'est redressé par rapport au
dollar aujourd'hui les deux monnaies
sont à parité entre temps l'économie
américaine a beaucoup souffert
conséquence lui en septembre scandales
financiers à répétition
les investisseurs ont déserté le dollar
ils ont acheté de l'euro et l'euro est
remonté un euro fort ça des avantages le
pétrole facturées en dollars est moins
cher et le prix du litre à la pompe
hausse cela dit il ne faudrait pas que
l'euro s'emballe attention aujourd'hui
un euro trop fort serait un danger pour
notre croissance est connue parce que
sinon ça limiterait nos exportations
notamment celles de l'allemagne et en
allemagne le seul moteur ce sont des
exportations
si jamais vous avez un euro qui est trop
fort risque de casser également la
croissance chez nous car le succès de
l'euro ne veut pas dire que tout va bien
en europe
au contraire la croissance est toujours
fragile en fait les marchés trop juste
que cela va encore moins bien aux états
unis pour le moment